[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya rosa pérez más se gusta
lista en el estudio rosa bienvenida
buena mañana de miércoles vamos a
dedicar esta revista de prensa a
comentar el mayor análisis realizado por
un medio de comunicación sobre el
impacto digamos de nosotros la opción
humana sobre el cambio climático se
trata de un estudio llamado los
imposibles de gharyan que lo firma
damián changing bueno es de raúl
exactamente como dice the gardian se
trata de la mayor compilación de
análisis de los llamados estudios de
atribución que precisamente lo que
quieren determinar es el vínculo directo
entre las emisiones contaminantes
generadas por la acción humana y su
participación en el calentamiento global
y por lo tanto en el cambio climático
con fenómenos meteorológicos extremos en
particular y la conclusión a la que
llega este análisis de the gardian es
que no hay duda de que la enorme
cantidad de emisiones de carbono
generadas por la actividad humana están
alterando el clima hacia nuevos extremos
desastrosos bien como decíamos se va
este análisis en más de 500 estudios
disponibles de la base de datos carbon
brief que ha compartido exclusivamente
con este medio británico y el mayor
hallazgo de este análisis y de aquí el
título es que una docena de los eventos
meteorológicos más graves desde olas de
calor terrestres a horas de calor
marítimas entre otras habrían sido casi
imposibles sin el calentamiento global
causado por el hombre y de estos 12
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
destacamos algunos como las olas de
calor consecutivas y cada vez más
extremas sobre todo en el hemisferio
norte pero también y particularmente
grave en el polo norte o las olas de
calor submarinas también en el océano
pacífico pero quizás lo que llama más la
atención y es que globalmente se
atribuye directamente a la acción humana
y dentro de estos doce imposibles el
aumento de la temperatura global desde
1850 hasta la fecha hasta ahora y esta
fecha 1850 recordemos es muy importante
porque en ese momento se empiezan a
medir
el incremento de temperatura porque en
1850 se considera todavía la época
preindustrial y todos los compromisos a
los que se llega por ejemplo en las
scope climáticas pues fijan el límite
del aumento de la temperatura respecto a
1850 y lo que destacan distintos
analistas en este informe es que si ya
es grave y asombrosa la velocidad con la
que se están produciendo estos fenómenos
extremos teniendo en cuenta que la
temperatura sólo ha aumentado un 1 grado
respecto a 1850 las consecuencias pueden
ser inimaginables si realmente llegamos
a la temperatura a un aumento de la
temperatura de un grado y medio o dos
grados que es más o menos el compromiso
al que ahora hacemos a frente así es
rosa pero más allá de estos dos
acontecimientos extremos que estaba
planteando que hubieran sido imposible
también sin acción humana en qué medida
nosotros hemos contribuido a alterar el
clima del planeta lo vemos en la
siguiente gráfica raúl vemos de color
rojo cuando los acontecimientos han
estado muy influidos por la acción
humana en amarillo
no hay tanta influencia detectada en
azul cuando no ha habido influencia o no
se ha detectado y en gris cuando no hay
datos suficientes para determinar esta
influencia y vemos que en la primera
barra en los fenómenos en los que se
detectan más influencia de la acción
humana tenemos las olas de calor
terrestre en segundo lugar las olas de
calor marinas en tercer lugar los
incendios en cuarto las tormentas luego
las sequías y las lluvias y las
inundaciones todas que una importante
influencia humana como vemos excepto los
que tienen más relación con el frío la
nieve y el hielo pero déjame que dé otro
dato y es que nos dice the gardian que
una de cada tres muertes causadas por el
calor extremo en las últimas tres
décadas fue el resultado directo del
calentamiento global causado por el
hombre y rosas' estudios también muestra
los lugares más afectados por estos
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos no
exactamente y en general no son los que
más participan al calentamiento global y
es que hay que dejar claro una cosa que
siempre que hablamos de acción humana es
un concepto un poco ambiguo no hay que
tener cuenta que los países ricos son
más responsables que los países pobres
de las personas ricas son más
responsables que las pobres y también a
la industria de este modelo económico
basado en el crecimiento sin freno no
hay tan de regulado y precisamente como
nos dice the gardian el sur global que
es él es el menos responsables de la
crisis climática pero alberga a muchas
de las personas más vulnerables a sus
efectos no y entre otros datos que nos
da vemos como américa latina se
encuentran los países más afectados por
la mortalidad por el aumento de la
mortalidad causada por el calentamiento
global generado por la acción humana
vemos en primer lugar el país más
afectado ecuador en segundo lugar
colombia luego guatemala perú kuwait
brasil bien entre otros conclusiones de
este informe rosa que el cambio
climático ya no es el futuro sino el
presente pero también es la explicación
de muchos fenómenos del pasado por otro
lado que los acontecimientos extremos
inéditos digamos que al ser precisamente
y fenómenos inéditos son difícil de
anticipar y por lo tanto podemos ver
cada vez más daños humanos y materia así
que a pesar de las advertencias las
políticas no están a la altura y de
hecho déjame acabar con esta cita dicen
el hecho de que actualmente nos
dirijamos a un aumento de temperatura de
3 grados a la luz de estos estudios es
por supuesto aterrador y 3 grados
centígrados no será tres veces peor el
daño será exponencial no lineal rosa
bueno muchísimas gracias por este
informe bien revelador y pues también en
que cada día más nos damos cuenta del
daño que le hacemos a nuestro planeta y
que necesitamos cambiar absolutamente ya
rosa mañana nuevos con más revista de
prensa nosotros pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día